l'objectif de cette start-up simplifier
la mobilité des habitants dans leur
quotidien pour les jeunes sans permis de
conduire les personnes âgées ou les
personnes ne disposant pas de véhicule
les lignes de bus sont parfois une
véritable galère l'entreprise permet
donc aux murs y autant de se déplacer
dans des zones difficilement accessibles
en transports en commun à un coût réduit
le principe du service c'est qu'on a une
application mobile qui permet de
réserver le passage du véhicule en temps
réel ou à l'avance le véhicule va
s'arrêter à moins de 200 mètres de là où
vous êtes et va vous conduire à moins de
200 mètres de votre point d'arrivée
finale et ceci pour un prix maximum de 2
euros par trajet vannes oc lancé en 2019
et des buts depuis décembre ses premiers
essais dans la ville des mureaux grâce
au pôle territorial de coopération
économique afin que acteurs du
territoire nous avons initié un
programme le booster des entrepreneurs
pour
accompagner les porteurs de projets à se
lancer dans l'entreprenariat et nous
avons été ravis d'accueillir vannes ou
dans ce programme
kkr a été lauréat du
coup de coeur du de la session booster
le service est disponible 7 jours sur 7
de 4 heures du matin jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin le lendemain fait plus proche et
complice est disponible à toute heure et
a que deux heures de trop en fait genre
ci a besoin de quelque chose faire
quelque chose à faire un rapide on prend
20 ans et en plus ça arrive ça arrive
vite en période de corona tout ça qu'on
vide les bus on est plutôt regroupés
alors que renault bahia souvent une ou
deux personnes beaucoup de monde
l'autre objectif de la start up et de
diminuer l'empreinte carbone et la
congestion urbaine avec des trajets
collectif la course peut être commandé
en temps réel ou à l'avance via
l'application mobile vanot